[Music]
ten-year-old takari Tatum is on a
mission did you hear that a mission to
help kids learn about mental health and
cope with tough times in America nearly
8 million young people experience mental
health disorders and one in five say the
pandemic had a significant negative
impact on their lives so takari wrote a
book it's called Snap it based on his
own experience with loss and mental
health struggles during this pandemic
he's also founder of the rubber band
mentality and is the youngest person to
win the National Alliance on Mental
Illness young leader award in Georgia
takari we welcome you to CBS morning's
your favorite Morning Show so let's talk
about what happened to you you lost your
grandfather and your aunt during the
pandemic let's focus on your grandfather
in particular because you described him
as your best friend how did his death
affect you my grandfather's death
affected me in very many negative ways
um at school I just didn't feel it I was
not my usual energetic self and even at
home I would just slouch in bed and cry
and I wasn't I wasn't feeling energetic
or full yeah and you got into a couple
fights where people started teasing you
about crying and being sad and then you
didn't like the way you were behaving
and so you thought what
I thought I I needed to get back into my
how I standed and how I was usual right
I had to get back into that um
mentality so I created snap it bracelets
anytime you feel stressed or anxious you
snap it to remind yourself to stay cool
Karma Collective and to breathe cool
calm and collected I like that right I
like that too but what do you want kids
to know I wanted kids to know that
they're not alone alone in what in their
darkest times and when maybe even a
family member dies their parents are
divorcing that that's always going on
every second of every day so what advice
do you give to kids who might not feel
like they have a safe space to talk
whether it's at home or at school
sometimes kids hold things and sometimes
adults both things we do it as well what
advice do you give them
um some advice that I give them is that
just keep going and keep moving on with
your life and make sure that you know
that it's always going to get better and
that it's not always going to be like
that it is always going to get better
yeah you're only 10 years old you're an
advocate you're an author do you what do
you want to be when you grow up oh good
question when I grow up I want to be a
meteorologist and as you might know my
book was act the forward of the book was
also written by the head meteorologist
of 11 alive Chesley McNeil and he wrote
the auth he wrote the forward and I
actually went over to his headquarters
at 11 alive and I saw how he works and
how he does all of his meteorologist
things oh nice so I see go ahead I see
you've got the one rubber band on this
wrist that you snap for yourself and
you've got three on the other what's the
significance of the other ones
um the significance of the other ones
were for you
[Laughter]
Tony you knew what you were doing right
there
let's go in that direction okay but I
like what you said when you said it made
me sad talking about your grandfather I
would go to school brokenhearted and
come home heartbroken
what are you saying there takari with
those words I was saying that um even
seeing other people even brought me down
more because I knew that a lot of people
were going through the same thing that I
was going through in the same time and
even during covid we had to do virtual
learning and that took a toll on a lot
of other people because they were just
slouching on their camera crying even or
sometimes not even having their camera
on so how does snapping it help
um it scientifically proven that feeling
the sting of the rubber band against her
skin actually it may seem counteractive
but it actually helps with your mental
illness and helps you take a breath and
look back on what's going on in your
life kind of snap back into reality yeah
take a breath and focus I like that I
like that I like that you brought three
friends see in addition to being an
author he's also very considerate and
thoughtful in giving we like this
congratulations to you congratulations
good job yeah thank you very much his
book can I have mine please yeah get
mines too Tony is book snapping is on
sale now wherever you like to buy your
books